Many of us want to start our own businesses.
Public space is filled with reports of new
ventures. But the reporting on entrepreneurship
is heavily skewed in one particular direction:
towards people who have started new kinds
of businesses, pioneers who have pushed the
boundaries of commerce by creating a wholly
original offering, usually through the help
of an innovative piece of technology. The
new entrepreneurs might, for example, have
invented an app for measuring and controlling
the humidity of clothes’ closets, or they
might have come up with a tiny sensor that
can detect hunger in domestic animals or have
built a social platform to connect people
planning a trip to Italy. This emphasis on
novelty can leave us feeling that the chief
and correct way to become an entrepreneur
is invariably going to be through radical,
technologically-based innovation. We may therefore,
as we contemplate an entrepreneurial future,
ask ourselves (with increasing panic) what
entirely unthought-of idea we might ourselves
come up with to propel us forward. In our
frenzy, the answers we arrive at may start
to lean towards the implausible, the trite
or the naive. But there is another path. Most
of the economy is made up of businesses doing
stuff that people have always been doing or
have been doing for a very long time: making
daily bread or shirts or trousers, teaching
languages or giving travellers a bed for the
night, raising animals or fixing teeth. In
other words, most businesses operate in areas
that economists call ‘mature’, sectors
where it’s rather hard to come in and make
a surprising fortune. But that doesn’t mean
these sectors should be ignored. Far from
it; there are a plethora of hugely meaningful
possibilities hiding for us in plain sight
on account of one, perhaps surprising fact
about the economy: a majority of businesses
don’t love what they do. We might make a
basic distinction between two kinds of businesses:
– pragmatic businesses – businesses of
love. Pragmatic businesses are everywhere.
They almost define for us what we think business
is in its essence. They know how to make their
product or service with a sound degree of
competence, but there is a practical, unidealistic
edge to the way they go about things. There
isn’t anything very powerful drawing them
to their particular offering. They might easily
have been doing something else. They don’t
care about the long-term; the business is
only a vehicle for an underlying financial
purpose. One eye is always focused on how
to sell. If the owners didn’t have to work,
they almost certainly wouldn’t. Such pragmatic
businesses may do fine, or even very well,
for a long time, but the motivations are easy
enough to spot. A discerning eye can tell
something crucial within minutes of walking
through the door: this is not being done with,
or for, love. Pragmatic businesses dominate
the economy. One might say that over 85% of
businesses fall into this category. But there
are parts of the economy, and they are heavily
in the minority, where things are being done
very differently.
Businesses of love produce many varied things,
but there are underlying principles holding
them together. Here love means: – a total
commitment to excellence of a given product
or service. – a desire to reinvest almost
all profit into guaranteeing excellence. – a
focus on the long-term, because the business
is – for its owners – the meaning of life.
There is no interest in selling the firm now,
or perhaps ever. The dearest wish might be
to give it to someone you love, like your
child.
© Flickr/cskk
– love means you’d almost do it for free
– and don’t only because you need to live,
you need to pay your employees and you want
the business to be able to last into the long
term. The product or service is what you love
and you love it inordinately. Businesses of
love are the sort where the owner has scoured
the world for the best kind of flour and wakes
up excitedly at dawn to check on the progress
of each of the loaves; the aircraft factory
where the workers think of every plane they
are building like a relative they will always
care for; the stationery shop where notebooks
and paper are viewed as objects of beauty
rather than utility; the travel agency that
won’t rest until it knows it clients have
enjoyed their trips rather than just paid
for them; the sandwich store that views a
fine avocado and chicken roll as one of the
authentic joys of a tricky life. Businesses run for love are not always successful
in the standard financial sense of the term.
Some might just be returning a little over
3% a year. But for these enterprises, money
is only ever a means to a greater, more purposeful
end. There are huge opportunities to hand
for any would-be entrepreneurs because most
of the economy is in the hands of people who
don’t love what they are doing. Most law
firms, dentists’ offices, hotels and bakeries
aren’t in it for love. They may be efficient
and canny, but they are – ultimately – just
waiting to sell up. We don’t need to be
very original to succeed, we don’t need
to have invented anything very new; we just
need – to make sense of our lives and to
make an honest living along the way – to
offer the world something we love a little
more intensely than most people do. .
Thank you for commenting, liking and subscribing.
Our book 'A Job To Love' is a practical guide to finding fulfilling work, to find out more, follow the link on your screen now.